tout le monde ou presque sait
aujourd'hui que les velociraptor de
jurassic park sont trop grands pour être
de véritables velociraptor mais
aviez-vous remarqué que le dinosaure de
jurassic park lui il était trop petit
pour être un véritable dinosaure
et oui le dinosaures de jurassic park
est la moitié de la taille que devrait
faire un deal of other adultes alors
évidemment vous pourriez dire qu'il
s'agit d'un deal of other juvénile qui
vient juste d'être introduit dans son
enclos mais à ça je réponds avez vous
remarqué que ce dinosaure il a une
collerette
alors oui le fait que le deal of other à
une collerette et complètement centrale
à la scène où nedry se fait attaquer par
le dinosaure est justement avez vous
réfléchi à la présence de cette
collerette cette collerette il s'agit
d'un organe encombrants coloré que le
dinosaure montre ostensiblement et ça ça
fait penser beaucoup aux arcs temps
modernes que sont les oiseaux et
notamment aux plans et aux oiseaux de
paradis qui ont ces longues que ces
longues plumes qu'il déploie pour
séduire les femelles
donc sachant qu'en tant que dinosaures
le dinosaure est quand même très proche
des oiseaux modernes on pourrait
s'imaginer que cette grande crête coloré
et encombrantes comme la queue du paon
serait l'apanage des mâles dinosaures et
pas des femelles
or rappelez-vous sur jurassic park tous
les dinosaures sont censés être des
femelles
alors maintenant si vous conjuguez le
fait que le dinosaure est peut-être un
mal avec le fait que cet âge une veine
il est ce qu'on ne serait pas en face
d'un dinosaure qui serait né
naturellement à jurassic park et qui ne
serait pas né des éprouvettes du docteur
goût est-ce qu'on ne serait pas la face
à la preuve que ça fait en fait très
très longtemps que les ingénieurs
d'ingende ont perdu le contrôle de l'île
alors rappelez vous à la fin du film on
a le dr grant qui découvrent des oeufs
de dinosaures qui montre que ces
dinosaures se reproduise en liberté mais
il s'agit de relativement frais
relativement récent on va dire le deal
of oz or il est quand même d'une bonne
taille même s'il ya encore la moitié de
la taille d'un adulte il est quand même
d'une bonne taille ce qui quand même
suggère que ça ferait super longtemps
que le contrôle de jurassic park aurait
été perdu
cependant at on raison de faire
l'hypothèse que seuls les dix le formal
avait une collerette parce que si on
regarde l'animal qui a directement
inspiré le design du deal aux faisans de
jurassic park
il s'agit du lézard à collerette le
lézard à collerette australien
chlamydiose aux russes et chez ces
lézards à collerette et bien la
collerette est à la fois présente chez
les mâles mais aussi chez les femelles
et ça c'est quelque chose de très
intéressant alors pourquoi les mâles et
les femelles ont une collerette chez le
lézard australien et bien c'est parce
que chez le lézard australien les mâles
utilisent effectivement la collerette
pour la parade nuptiale mais les
femelles et les mâles utilisent aussi
leurs collerette à des fins de défense
cette collerette fait paraître l'animal
plus gros qu'il ne l'est quand il l'a
déploie donc face à un prédateur et
cette collerette elle est aussi de
couleurs vives et notamment de couleur
rouge et ça c'est un signe généralement
de danger c'est un signe de toxicité est
le prédateur qui est devant ce lézard à
collerette et qui réfléchit à deux fois
avant de l'attaquer et bien ça donne aux
lézards à collerette juste deux secondes
le temps de s'en aller deux secondes de
répit qui peuvent signifier la vie ou la
mort pour ce petit lézard
donc il existe une probabilité non
négligeable que chez les dinosaures de
jurassic park les mâles comme les
femelles est une collerette
alors est-ce que le deal of other de
jurassic park utilise sa collerette pour
la défense la réponse est non pas
vraiment mais en même temps la façon
dont le deal of other utilise sa
collerette dans le film jurassic park
elle n'a aucun sens d'un point de vue
biologique
il déploie sa collerette avant
d'attaquer nedry or un prédateur quand
ils attaquent une proie il va pas
soudainement déployer une collerette ou
des attributs visible il va essayer de
rester le plus discret possible pour
surprendre sa proie
donc c'est complètement stupide de crier
de déployer une collerette avant
d'attaquer sa proie quand bien même on
lui jette du venin dessus alors l'autre
possibilité ce serait qu'en fait le deal
aux faisans se sentent menacés par les
drire et du coup il déploie sa
collerette cris et lui jette du mna afin
de l'éloigner afin de le repousser le
problème c'est qu'après ils le mangent
donc on voit pas très bien pourquoi le
deal of other aurait d'abord peur de
nedry pour ensuite le dévorer la
troisième possibilité c'est que le
dinosaure en fait se sent attirée
sexuellement par nedry
et lui sort le grand jeu à grands coups
de collerettes et de cris de chant etc
et dans ce cas-là ça voudrait dire que
ce qui se passe dans la voiture et qui
se déroule hors champ on voit la voiture
se secouer puis la caméra se tourne en
fait c'est pas la caméra qui se tourner
pour nous cacher de la violence c'est en
fait une scène classés x et le pauvre
nedry restera à jamais marqué par la
découverte de ce à quoi ressemble les
organes génitaux des dinosaures bref
tout ça pour dire que la façon dont le
film traite l'utilisation de la
collerette chez dinosaures ne nous
indiquent pas grand chose sur la façon
dont un véritable animal utiliserait une
collerette c'est plutôt une façon très
très fantasmé spectaculaire juste fait
pour le cinéma d'utiliser la collerette
mais revenons à nos les arts à
collerette donc ne laissa à collerette
nous apprennent que oui il est possible
qu'à la fois des mâles et des femelles
puissent posséder une collerette et que
donc notre dinosaures de jurassic park
pourrait très bien être une femelle avec
une collerette et donc être tout à fait
issues des laboratoires d'ingende oui
mais rappelez vous je vous ai dit que
cette collerette chez les femelles elle
était utilisée pour la protection donc
les mâles l'utilisent pour la parade et
la protection et chez les femelles il
utilise pour la protection
or le dinosaure at il de bonnes raisons
d'avoir peur le dinosaure at il des
prédateurs et bien la réponse est non le
dinosaure vient de la formation cayenne
tas en amérique du nord et dans cette
formation cayenne tu as le dinosaure est
le plus grands théropodes vivant il est
le plus grand prédateur le prédateur
dominant de cet écosystème dinosaure n'a
donc pas de prédateurs et il n'y aurait
donc aucune raison que les femelles
arbore une collerette donc on en revient
à l'hypothèse que dit le faiseur serait
un mal en réalité
sauf que ça c'était l'état des
connaissances en 1993 quand le film est
sorti mais depuis on a fait des progrès
on a fait des découvertes de nouveaux
fossiles qui indique qu'il devait
exister des prédateurs plus grand que
dinosaures à l'époque où la formation
cayenne tassé déposé et ce dinosaure
plus grand c'est cayenne ta puce il
s'agit d'empreintes de pas fossilisées
d'un grand dinosaure théropode d'un
grand dinosaure carnivore et c'est en
panne de cartes à puce
on en a retrouvé des fossiles en 2017 au
lesotho qui sont absolument gigantesque
qui appartenait à l'animal qui dépasse
ed très très loin la taille du dinosaure
adultes et comme son nom l'indiqué
caliente à puce qui tient son nom de la
formation kaïn tàu le dinosaure a été
trouvée caliente à puce et est
totalement contemporain de dinosaures
dont qu'il existait bel et bien à
l'époque du dinosaure des méga
théropodes encore plus grand que
dinosaures et qui était susceptible
d'être des prédateurs de dinosaures
alors évidemment le lesotho c'est pas
tout à côté de l'amérique mais il faut
vous rappeler qu'on est au début du
jurassique et qu'au début du jurassique
même si la pangée a commencé à se
fracturer ça ne veut pas dire que le
continent pangéa est complètement
fracturée au jurassique il y a encore
beaucoup de dinosaures qui sont communs
à l'amérique et à l'afrique comme par
exemple le brachiosaure on retrouve le
brachiosaure en amérique du nord et on
retrouve son pendant africain girafe à
titan en tanzanie et les deux sont
tellement similaires que certains
proposent qu'il s'agit en fait du même
genre
donc oui le dinosaure qui a fait les
empreintes de cayenne ta puce géant en
afrique au volet auto peut très bien
avoir aussi vécu en amérique du nord
mais on en n'a pas encore retrouvé les
fossiles en tout cas pour ce qui est du
film ça nous indique que finalement
après avoir fait le tour de la question
mathema noah et bien oui il est tout à
fait possible que les femelles
dinosaures est arboré une collerette
probablement à des fins de défense comme
les mâles eux arboraient cette même
collerette à des fins de séduction et de
défense aussi exactement comme on le
voit aujourd'hui chez le lézard à
collerette
donc c'est presque par erreur finalement
que les designers du film jurassic park
qui ont créé un deal au faisan à
collerette donc suggérant qu'il aurait
pu s'agir d'un mal on en fait anticipé
la découverte d'empreintes de cayenne ta
puce géante qui en démontrant
l'existence d'un potentiel prédateur a
dit l'offshore et bien justifie que des
dinosaures femelle est possédé une
collerette
donc voilà c'est le génie accidentelle
de jurassic park d'avoir anticipé de
plusieurs années de presque 15 ans la
découverte d'une justification à
l'existence de cette collerette chez un
dinosaure femelles
[Musique]